hey everybody it's mike from overflows
and in this video i'm going to show you
how to enable tick replay on
ninjatrader now this is an important
function that you have to make sure you
have enabled when you open up
an order flows trader chart or indicator
and let me just show you the difference
so for example right if i open up a new
chart
and i don't have tick replay enabled
right if this box right
when it's checked it's enabled if it's
unchecked it's disabled
and i open up an order flows trader
chart
i'll just show you what it looks like
right you're going to say hey the
software doesn't work you know you're
out there
sending you know selling me some scammy
product it's not working it looks like
this
you know that's because you have to
enable the tick
replay right so if you were to open up a
chart and you have tick replay
enabled it's going to look proper
right and the reason why you need to
have this enabled is because it
the way the software handles the data is
it's going to read the past data that's
already
come in as actual data and it will give
you a proper
footprint chart if you have it disabled
when you open up a new chart it will
just start reading the data as
it comes in but if you want to have the
data showing
on your chart like this then you have to
enable tick replay
so again when you
go to open a chart click this button
that says
tick replay now if you don't have this
button what that means is you don't have
tick replay enabled
so go to tools okay go to options
market data show tick replay if this box
is not
checked okay if this is just blank like
that
whoops you know like this
you're not going to have that feature
when you open up a chart
okay you'll notice here it doesn't say
show tick replay now again you know some
people
you know they don't want to take the
extra time to enable it and they just
want to say oh you know
the software doesn't have it so you know
it's it's faulty no it you have to
enable it
okay go to tools go to options
go to market data go to show
tick replay check it takes two seconds
click apply click ok that way when you
go to open
up a chart
it's there for you to check
right
now i'm using two screens and for some
reason it's popping up on my other
screen
here we go so there all right so your
chart appears
the way it should be and especially it's
important especially if you're running
um you know my order flows based
indicators
you also need to have that checked but
you know i go through the instructions
for that
same way um you know for the different
indicators just make sure you have it
checked
so thanks and bye bye